bonjour à tous j'espère que vous allez
bien alors je vous fais une petite vidéo
improvisée mais à situation
exceptionnelle réponse exceptionnelle
petite vidéo improvisait pour vous dire
que comme vous le savez sans doute
vendredi c'est à dire avant-hier j'ai
lancé une campagne Ulule pour mon projet
de bande dessinée qui va s'appeler
filorama
et il se trouve et c'est ça qui est
incroyable que l'objectif des 100% a été
atteint en moins de 24 heures donc
j'avais lancé un objectif à 25000 euros
ce qui est quand même une somme assez
coquette et en moins de 24 heures on
avait dépassé les 25000 euros d'objectif
donc je suis un peu sous le choc pour
tout vous dire je pense même que ce sera
le titre de cette vidéo je suis sous le
choc parce que je ne pensais pas que
vous seriez aussi nombreux à vous
mobiliser pour ce projet alors autant
j'ai conscience d'être suivi par un
grand nombre de personnes que ce soit
sur Youtube ou sur Instagram ou les
plateformes de podcast
autant je fais la différence entre être
suivi et écouter ou regarder sur ces
plateformes publiques et faire un geste
de soutien tel que celui que vous avez
fait durant ces dernières 24 heures j'ai
conscience de ce que ça représente de la
confiance et du soutien que vous me
témoignez à travers ce geste et donc je
voulais vous en remercier officiellement
à travers cette vidéo alors j'ai
conscience que si vous m'avez apporté
votre soutien ce n'est pas seulement
parce que vous aimez mes vidéos parce
que vous aimez la philosophie c'est
aussi parce que vous croyez dans ce
projet de vulgarisation de la
philosophie sous la forme d'une bande
dessinée et c'est peut-être aussi parce
que vous vous êtes rendu sur la page
Ulule sur laquelle on a publié des
aperçus de cette bande dessinée des
pages qu'on a déjà réalisé avec Jules
mon dessinateur
et vous vous êtes rendu compte que le
travail est à la hauteur et
effectivement je pense que il ne faut
pas faire de fausses modestie Jules est
un excellent dessinateur qui arrive très
bien à restituer la personnalité de tous
les philosophes qui sont crédités dans
cette bande dessinée et donc vous êtes
rendu compte que le travail était bien
entamé et que la qualité au niveau
esthétique au niveau du rendu visuel
était au rendez-vous donc pour ceux qui
n'auraient pas encore eu l'occasion
d'aller sur cette page Ulule je vous
mets le lien dans la description et en
commentaire épinglé et pour ceux qui
peut-être
attendez d'être sûr que le projet soit
concrétisé pour apporter leur
contribution et bien maintenant sachez
que les 100% étant atteint
la BD vera le jour quoi qu'il arrive
donc vous pouvez la précommander sans
aucune crainte donc alors je vous parle
on a dépassé les 100% de l'objectif et
donc la question que vous vous posez
sans doute c'est qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire est-ce que ça veut dire que la
campagne bulle va s'arrêter et bien non
parce que sur l'UL on peut dépasser sans
aucun problème les 100% de l'objectif on
peut atteindre les 200 300 les 1000% ce
n'est pas du tout limité
et il faut savoir que à chaque nouveau
palier qui sera franchi 150 200 300 % et
bien vous allez débloquer un avantage
supplémentaire donc voilà pourquoi si
vous n'avez pas encore précommandé votre
bande dessinée je vous invite à le faire
et si vous l'avez déjà fait et bien vous
êtes nos meilleurs ambassadeurs c'est à
dire que je vous invite à parler de ce
projet autour de vous à partager la page
Ulule à toute personne qui serait
intéressée par la philosophie par la
vulgarisation philosophique parce que
c'est grâce à vous qu'on pourra
peut-être faire de philorama
le projet de référence en matière de
vulgarisation philosophique et
d'ailleurs je tiens à préciser que j'ai
été extrêmement touché par les
commentaires que vous m'avez laissé vous
les contributeurs notamment certaines
personnes qui me disaient que ça faisait
plusieurs mois parfois même plusieurs
années qu'il regardait mes vidéos qu'ils
écoutaient mes podcasts et qui n'avait
encore jamais eu l'occasion de me
soutenir de me soutenir matériellement
et que là ils ont eu envie de le faire
parce que c'est un projet dans lequel il
croit et sachez que si vous êtes dans ce
cas j'ai lu vos commentaires j'ai lu vos
témoignages et j'en étais très touché
parce que vous êtes la majorité
silencieuse vous êtes ceux qui écoutent
ou qui regardent mais qui ne font pas de
bruit qui ne s'expriment pas le fait de
savoir que cette bande dessinée ce
projet de bande dessinée vous a donné
envie de me soutenir c'est quelque chose
qui me touche beaucoup et même au-delà
de ça j'ai été contacté par plusieurs
sociétés privées ainsi que par des
libraires qui souhaitaient me passer
commande d'un grand nombre d'exemplaires
de la BD une fois qu'elle serait sortie
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai l'intuition
que cette bande dessinée ce n'est pas
juste un projet Ulule ce n'est pas
simplement un financement participatif
c'est probablement une bande dessinée
qui va s'inscrire dans la durée
évidemment je serai honoré ravi qu'elles
finissent dans les écoles ou qu'elles
finissent dans les bibliothèques
municipales parce que c'est comme ça que
j'ai découvert la lecture à titre
personnel par les bandes dessinées par
les Tintins dans ma bibliothèque
municipale de Béziers et donc évidemment
le fait d'être aussi contacté par des
organismes un peu plus importants un peu
plus imposants il y a c'est quelque
chose qui me touche beaucoup alors j'ai
aussi reçu quelques messages de
personnes qui n'ont pas précisément
compris le principe de ce financement
participatif et qui pensait que
contribuer vous les dire faire un don
non lorsque vous contribuez sur la page
Ulule vous ne faites pas un don vous
précommandez la bande dessinée c'est à
dire que vous l'achetez avant qu'elle
soit finalisée et vous la recevrez dès
qu'elle sera terminée
mais je me suis dit que c'était
peut-être plus simple de vous expliquer
la marche à suivre et notamment si vous
êtes sur version mobile
j'ai trouvé que c'était pas si évident
que ça de savoir comment il fallait
faire pour précommander l'un des packs
de la bande dessinée
donc lorsque vous êtes sur la version
mobile vous faites défiler le texte
jusqu'à arriver à la partie à quoi sert
le financement et là vous verrez tous
les packs qui vous sont proposés et vous
pouvez également accéder à la liste de
ses packs en cliquant sur l'onglet
contrepartie et c'est même le moyen le
plus simple et le plus direct d'accéder
au pack puisque vous choisissez le pack
qui vous intéresse et là vous pouvez le
précommander directement voilà je ne
vais pas faire plus long d'autant que la
pluie commence à me tomber sur les
lunettes en tout cas sachez que je vous
remercie du fond du coeur pour les
témoignages de soutien que vous m'avez
apporté durant ces dernières 24 heures
sachez que être soutenu financièrement
c'est très plaisant très agréable
évidemment mais symboliquement le
soutien que vous m'apportez à travers
votre présence à travers vos
commentaires et à travers votre
participation active à ce projet c'est
ça qui me touche le plus donc merci à
vous et je pense que je vous donnerai
des nouvelles dans les jours qui
viennent pour vous tenir informés de
l'avancement du projet sur ce prenez
soin de vous et à très bientôt